no one really like me because because of
the old man's spell so I wasn't really
close to any of the people there I was
working on Bernie Mac and Ken caucus the
director came on he was a big fan of my
band the grassroots so I heard that he
was doing the show the office I shot my
own talking head presented it to Greg
Daniels and they gave me the Halloween
episode with Steve Carell and the rest
as they say in the book because it's
such a great name
i trolled and did a lot trolling for
people who didn't really want me there
the character guy he's in the phrenic
said I can't believe he's making all
that music with just his mouth went in
the room where the director and says why
just come on close to me you've jumped
it up just me though out of focus I said
and I'll go that's what she said
and he says I don't can't believe you
meet all that music with sissy's mouth
and they come in people missed the first
two times the third time of viewing then
they saw it pretty much wasted in the
60s I made love to many many women often
outdoors in the rain in the mud it's
possible a man slipped in there'd be no
way of knowing but a boom John Krasinski
when we were due would we do the scenes
he suggested we do it like a David Mamet
play if you notice that once he had gets
Survivorman
but we're both in each other's space I
took one I don't know there's rapid-fire
stuff and it was so I turned out so much
fun
I was at the trial when when Toby was up
there testifying with blood all over me
with the parents of the the victims and
stuff bereaved the press no one even
noticed
no one saw me there no one paid any
attention they got the wrong guy
so let's create the Scranton strangler
next question please
Burt Burt Jacobs really good worm guy on
it Pennsylvania
well he was selling weapons-grade drugs
to the kids besides IDs military weapons
he had a slave trade trafficking thing
going on here there's so many things we
were gonna bring up you know his father
was found out to be an alien that I
asked Creed the other day I said did you
really kill me and he hemmed and hawed
for a long time and I really couldn't
get I really haven't got a straight
answer out of any any my personalities
about this thing it's it's a quandary
really very honest kept my trailer kept
all my wardrobe and kept some cameras
sound equipment when I came over
recently to visit the old sound stage
you know they they had you know
indictment against me basically so I
really can't go back there anymore
I was over in Romania for a while
shooting this noir Western called the
sister brothers I'll be going on tour to
promote my new album while the young
punk stands he probably escaped
obviously right away from the Scranton
police so he's probably off under an
assumed name doing the same thing I
always did fishing living in Canada
going back and forth you know selling
drugs killing people just having a
really good life